foreign
[Music]
recording this video so I'm going to do
another 10 minute game much like in the
previous video I'm not compromising on
the quality of the explanations
hopefully I'm compromising a little bit
on the breadth of the explanations
during the game but not after the game
so without further Ado we'll probably
get black this time
10 plus 0 is the time control so
obviously if things get down to the wire
I'm going to have to speed up my plan
once again for the second time
in a row we're facing E4 E5 and for the
second time in a row we are going to
repeat the four night Scotch I'm
anticipating e takes D4 this time and
indeed we have e takes D4 you might
remember if you're an assiduous speedrun
Watcher that in the previous video we
faced Bishop B4 which We examined very
carefully and the move there is Knight
takes E5 I incorrectly responded D5 this
of course is the main line of the four
night scotch and at this level we're
facing people who are very well versed
in this opening so Bishop before is the
main line white responds with Knight
takes Knight the bishop comes out to D3
this is mainstream Theory
and the point is to protect this Pawn
Knight 64 was a threat black castles
weak Castle
and here black is at a crossroad so our
opponent responds with D6 which is an
inaccuracy and if you will find if you
run this on references as we'll discuss
after the game the D6 is the choice of
many many GMS but in my opinion it is a
serious inaccuracy that faces black
width uh very serious difficulties if a
white responds accurately the main move
here is D5 which leads to a very
theoretical line and we'll talk a little
bit about that after the game the
problem with D6 is that it closes off
the Escape uh the path back for the dark
squared Bishop which means that when we
play Bishop G5 this actually is a very
Troublesome pin because either black has
to play G7 G5 and well that's obviously
a very weakening move or black basically
has to tolerate it but tolerating it is
a big issue because we actually can
accentuate the pressure on this Knight
which is exactly what we are going uh to
try to do so how can white try to
accentuate the pressure on F6 if you're
a habitual four-night Scotch player you
will know that this move is kind of in
your repertoire and it's not Queen F3
right Queen I'll talk about Queen F3
after the game Queen F3 is worse than it
looks the move that I have in mind is F2
F4
and the point is very straightforward
we're trying to prepare E5 and you might
look at this and say well isn't the E5
Square defended twice and only attacked
once yes it is but E5 first of all can
still be a very very strong move even if
it's a sacrifice because after Pawn
takes Pawn after the trade on E5 The
Rook opens up and the pressure on the
Knight is increased so a pawn sack on E5
is is very standard fare in the car in
the fortnite scotch so our opponent is
kind of wasting time on the other side
of the board which is giving us a lot of
time to you know cross the t's and Dot
the eyes
now one thing that
we need to be very careful about is our
King right when you make the move F4 as
I've said many many times you have to be
very careful about weakening this
diagonal that I've highlighted in blue
and the issue with the immediate E5 is
that after black takes and we take black
can actually drive the queen into D4 and
deliver a very nasty check which also
hits the bishop on H4 and if you drop
the bishop back in that position black
can take on E5 and
there's nothing remaining from our
pressure so let's throw in the move King
H1 which is a nice prophylactic move so
that we don't have to worry about any
headaches on that diagonal now we can
get down to business on the king side so
again the question is do we push E5 or
do we make another Preparatory move such
as Queen F3 with the intention of
bringing the Rook over to E1 largely
this is a matter of taste I think that
there are a lot of good moves in a
position like this if you're a very
aggressive player I think E5 is what
you'll lean toward but given that we
have this for the first time we have the
mainline for night Scotch for the first
time I'd like to play in a more
methodical manner so let's bring our
Queen out to F3 and of course we are
piling up indirectly on the night right
you should almost imagine that E5 is
already played Zen these moves start to
make a lot more sense because the
pressure on the Knight will increase
tremendously but the main idea of this
move is to bring all the toys to the
nursery party just to bring the Rook to
one and once The Rook is brought to E1
well then E5 is going to be a
devastating threat but before we rush to
play that move there's something that I
notice which is that the queen is also
x-raying the other Rook right The Rook
on A8 is undefended and it's being
x-rayed along this diagonal by the queen
so let's consider E5 uh another time
what happens after E5 well black is
obliged to take and we actually don't
have to take back on E5 in that position
I actually think we have a winning move
and what makes this winning move a
little bit hard to find is that it comes
on an area of the board which you might
not be paying attention to so what move
am I talking about E5 Pawn takes E5
notice that the bishop on C5 is then
also undefended we can just take the
pawn on C6 as simple as that and that's
a fork that is a standard Garden variety
of fork because we're attacking The Rook
on A8 and we're attacking the bishop on
C5 and I think the game is just over in
that position we go E5 our opponent
playing way way too quickly and just
making these mundane moves and after
Queen takes C6 I think black's position
is residable I don't see a wave for
black to to defend both of these pieces
at the same time
Queen D5 would serve that purpose but
obviously that square is protected by
our Knight the game is over
and apart from the fact that black has
these two pieces hanging you know
there's also this tremendous pressure on
the F6 Knight which is hamstringing
black even further but that doesn't
matter anymore
and I think that
he's kind of the beauty of coordinating
your pieces nicely which is that you
might have one idea in mind you might
have one General plan in mind but when
your pieces are active what you will
find is that very often you know the
entire world opens up to you and the
winning idea might come from a
completely unexpected Source okay e
takes F4 is just complete and total
desperation but let's try to be accurate
here we've got a pretty vast Choice uh
the the most straightforward move is
Queen takes A8 and that's probably the
move we're going to end up playing the
one very minor issue with Queen takes A8
is that
well maybe black will play G5 and start
developing a little bit of counter play
on the king side right black will
connect these pawns and our Bishop is
going to be pushed backwards uh so you
are actually can also take the dark
squared Bishop here and there's the case
to be made for taking a minor piece
rather than a rook in the middle game
because sometimes minor pieces are more
impactful in this type of position
uh but we could also take the horsey
first we could play Bishop takes F6 in
this position and this is a very nice
Intermezzo because the queen is
pressuring The Rook on E8 so Queen takes
F6 gets checkmated and pawn takes F6
completely ruins Black's King Side Pawn
structure which precludes any potential
counter play this move is very very good
actually and this is a move that I
anticipated and here again we have a
choice and as I've been saying really
from the very beginning when you have a
big decisive material advantage very
often you have three or four winning
paths in any given position and
whichever one you take really depends on
how you prefer to convert a winning
position the sort of Russian Schoolboy
move is Bishop takes d8 but that's not
the best move you shouldn't be aiming as
your first goal to trade Queens you
should be aiming uh to just get the most
winning position and if you look at this
position very carefully don't play Queen
takes Rook because then Black's Queen is
going to capture Our Queen and Black's
Queen is no longer going to be hanging
the best move is Bishop takes G7 right
because we're already losing that Bishop
anyway
we give it up for the pawn then we take
the bishop on C5 and as a result the
smoke is finally cleared wear up a full
piece but not only that look at Black's
King side Black's King is entirely in
shambles the F Pawn is hanging and black
has zero counter play to speak of we can
just start mopping up all of Black's
remaining pieces now we take on C7
hitting the bishop and hitting the pawn
this is very very straightforward uh
conversion
and this is game over now there's no
check made on G2 because that is safely
defended by our King
and now we come back and take the pawn
on F4
and we're following the general rule
that I've outlined many times which is
that you shouldn't go out of your way to
trade Queens but if an opportunity
presents itself then by all means trade
Queens because that often simplifies the
winning task Checkmate on H7 a very
simple game but a good introduction to
the main line of the fortnite scotch
right I like to play Simple games to
introduce uh deep lines because it's a
good way to just approach that line and
get your bearings so let's go through
the game quickly uh with an eye toward
understanding the uh the essence of the
mainline for a night Scotch which we are
facing for the first time so
in the previous game we faced the
immediate Bishop B4 which is an old move
that I had forgotten how to play against
my response was D5 and then the center
closed up my opponent played a really
really nice game but the testing move
here is Knight takes C5 as you might
remember and hopefully you'll remember
that after Knight's AC4 the critical
move here is Queen's a G4 hitting the
Knight and hitting the G7 Pawn
and you can refer to that video for a
more in-depth explanation of the theory
in this game we Face the main line which
is e takes D4 Knight takes D4 and Bishop
f8 to B4
which is a very logical developing move
earlier in the speedrun we faced Knight
takes D4 which is the choice of most
newer players who are tempted to kind of
release the tension after Queen takes D4
Black's position is very cramped white
is already threatening uh the nasty move
E5 and Black's position really is is no
good now apart from Bishop B4 there are
a couple of very interesting
Alternatives the one that I have played
with black is Bishop to C5 this is an
alternate development of the bishop this
immediately pressures the Knight and
kind of forces white to commit and here
my kind of official recommendation is to
bring the bishop out to E3 and create uh
an x-ray against Black's bishop and here
if black falls asleep in castles then
Knight takes C6 wins a piece because we
hit the queen black has to take back and
doesn't matter with which Pawn we take
the bishop on C5 so here it's very
important for black to be alert and to
bring this bishop back onto a defended
Square the line that I recommend here
for white is Queen to D2 black typically
castles kingside and White Castle's
Queen side which leads to a very
interesting battle this is still very
well known uh this position is still
very well studied and I believe that
white is a little bit better here
according to the sort of latest Theory I
won't delve into this line because we
have plenty to discuss in the context of
Bishop B4 it's important to get the move
order right I found that players who are
just learning the fortnite scotch very
often get the move order wrong and if
you get them over wrong you actually can
get a really bad position here with
white first things first do not play
Bishop to D3 immediately because that
simply drops the Knight on D4 okay it's
really important to take Black's Knight
first in order to be able to bring this
bishop out to D3 it's also important not
to try to use your common sense because
if you do that you might look at this
position and say well okay I I see that
there is a pin here I see that the pawn
on e4 is hanging so let's play the move
F3 but this isn't like the Sicilian F3
is a tremendously weakening move because
black has the capacity in this line to
open up the center at a moment's notice
with the help of D5 so if you play F3
black is probably going to Castle and
after you make a developing move black
is going to play D5 and you are going to
be punished sorely for weakening your
king like that
so it's important here to take on C6 now
black can take with a d-pawn but this
just leads to a bad end game because the
king is driven out into the center
Black's King side uh queenside Pawn
structure is really really bad and I'm
gonna open up chess space really quickly
here to tell you what the best move is
in this position I'm pretty sure it's
Bishop to D2 but let me verify that
boronite Scotch takes okay D takes C6
Queen takes D King T6 yeah Bishop D2 is
the best move
and as is often the case if black plays
Bishop C3 uh Bishop C3 and Knight E4
we simply Castle queenside
and if black moves the king
and then black loses the Knight we go
rookie one and then F3 and the next move
picks off the Knight and if black plays
Bishop to D7 we play Bishop takes Pawn
Rook G8 is forced and now the bishop
drops back to D4 in order to protect the
F2 Pawn Black's position is awful we
have the bishop pair and we have a huge
initiative nothing to talk about here
after Bishop to D2 okay the best move is
Bishop to E6 bringing out the bishop and
now we can bring the other Bishop out to
E2
and once black plays the move I don't
know like King E8 we can secure the E4
Pawn with the move F3 and with the
Queens off the board F3 makes a lot more
sense then we can continue by castling
Queen side and white just has a pretty
big Advantage here so DC is nothing to
worry about
after B takes C6 we play Bishop D3 to
over protect the E4 Pawn
same thing I said last time if you use
your common sense you might come up with
the move Bishop to G5 and you might
think well this is a more active way to
defend the E4 Pawn we're pinning black
snipe who can tell me what exactly is
wrong with the move Bishop to G5 how
does black punish this move why is it
wrong
and this is actually a very common type
of mistake yeah the problem is that
black plays H6 now you don't want to
give your Bishop away that's pretty
obvious because you're giving black the
bishop air and you're giving black
massive pressure on the Knight and if
you play Bishop H4 black can play G5 and
force this bishop onto G3 and black
simply white simply loses the pawn on e4
and this is a very Troublesome scenario
now the game continues here
um according to the engine white can eke
out equality uh with Queen to D4 but I
don't recommend this line at all and if
white plays Queen E2 here then black and
simply Castle kingside
and if white picks up the night black
plays rookie eight Bishop B5 and Bishop
to D6 is very strong here because white
is going to lose uh this bishop it's
attacked too many times
and so don't play Bishop G5 again don't
play F3 don't play Bishop D2 here
although that is I'm pretty sure Bishop
D2 actually is a move here but it's not
a very good one I mean black can simply
castle and this is just too passive
right your Bishop doesn't belong on D2
in this position instead you play Bishop
to D3 and from a strategic standpoint
the reason you play this move is because
you're not afraid of doubling your queen
side pawns and the reason you're not
afraid of doubling them is because it's
a very very steep price for Black to pay
to give up the dark squared bishop and
the reason why is that once our Bishop
comes out to G5 you saw something like
this in the game this pin against the
Knight coupled with all the dark Square
pressure that we can exert makes it
totally unjustified for black to give
out that Bishop so one way that this can
play out let's say black plays castles
uh King side
you know we castle kingside and black
plays D6 kind of like in the game we
play Bishop to G5 and black is really
really really suffering on the dark
squares and white has this plan that we
executed in the game of playing F4 and
E5 black really really needs to drop
this bishop back to E7 so don't be
afraid of getting your pawns doubled in
general but particularly in this
position so castles is fine
alternatively black can play the
immediate D5 and most times this
transposes into the main line after Pawn
takes Pawn takes castles castles we get
the same position that we would have
gotten in the game if sorry
uh if black had gone D5 in this position
which is considered the best move by far
as well as the main line so I'm pretty
sure that we're still going to face it
but after D5 the line that I recommend
is uh e takes D5
C takes D5
and here we reach a branching off point
where white has several very interesting
continuations the traditional Main Line
uh the traditional Mainline is Bishop to
G5 and typically black responds by
reinforcing the D5 Pawn with the move C6
so that Knight takes D5 is not an issue
white continues to pressure the night
with Queen's F3 but here you begin to
see why Queen F3 is not as dangerous of
a move as it might appear so the most
popular move is Bishop E7 but black
doesn't actually have to reinforce the
Knight black can also play the bishop
back to D6 in order to pressure H2 and
if white plays Bishop takes F6 which is
one of the main lines black responds by
taking with the queen and as you know
when the Queens are off the board the
sort of importance of the ruined Pawn
structure greatly diminishes Black's
King is a little bit flimsy but white
doesn't have the Firepower to develop an
attacker on Black's King so the pawn
structure is unpleasant but it's not a
big problem the black's King is now
weakened and white has a tiny smidge of
an edge here but this is not the line
that I recommend to most Club players
because this is not as fun and most
games here end in a draw
instead the line that I really like that
really caught my eye is actually this
very flexible move uh H3 now this is the
actual recommendation uh that I think
will challenge most players under 22
2300 uh and even some title players so
the point of H3 is simple it's a
flexible improving move it controls the
g-force square and you're preparing to
bring the queen out to F3 if you bring
the queen out immediately you're
obviously I mean you're potentially
walking into Bishop G4 move although you
can actually start with Queen F3 still I
like H3 a lot because you're not really
revealing your intentions now typically
black responds with C6 in order to
reinforce the D5 Pawn but a lot of newer
players are going to be lost at sea in a
position like this and it's very easy
for black to go wrong if instead black
plays a move like rookie 8 for example
white brings the queen out to F3 and
already black is experienced saying some
issues let's say black tries to play
this without going C6 so what move comes
to mind here for black if you're looking
at this for the first time maybe
somebody in the chat can tell me like
what would you play here with black just
for me to get a sense of how people are
thinking
okay so H6 is one move we'll talk about
it in a second
I would imagine that some people would
probably bring this light squared Bishop
out let's say to B7 so Bishop B7 already
leads to a worse position because uh
White plays Bishop to G5
and this is like the Crux of white setup
we play Bishop G5
and just a moment please sorry
something happened to my chest base I'm
just Consulting my files
and this position is already very
unpleasant for black
okay I guess I'm just gonna have to turn
stalker Sean manually
just a second sorry
just basis
not acting very well
and this is going to be a bit of a dry
Exposition so if you're watching this on
YouTube you're like yeah
remember that the ultimate point of this
speedrun is to introduce you to an
opening repertoire that's going to last
you for like the majority of your chest
career so there's going to be stretches
of my explanation that are just Theory
and you just have to ask yourself like
what do you want you know do you want to
always be entertained or do you want to
actually learn some Theory so that you
can get good positions out of the
opening here you play Bishop G5 and
let's say that black plays H6 now you
can get a much better end game you can
take on F6 black takes on F6 you take on
F6 and compared to the version of the
end game that we consulted this is
simply a much better version for white
now again the pawn structure is kind of
bad and the best move here according to
the engine is a really interesting one
it's actually Rook a to B1
and the point of Rook a to B1 is to take
the sting out of the move Bishop takes
C3 because if black takes on C3 now then
you take back and you can see why you
put your Rook on B1 now it's attacking
the bishop on B7 and black is in big big
trouble here uh if black Bishop C6 you
can deploy your Rook into the game via
B4 and then you can shuttle it around to
the king side and start attacking all of
these vulnerable pawns it's really not
easy to play this position with black if
black plays C5 which I think is a very
natural move the Knight can jump into B5
you're threatening Knight C7 you're
threatening Knight D6 and if black
continues to push his C Pawn the bishop
finds a nice parking spot on F5 black
and Chase it away with rookie 5 the
bishop sort of ferries itself back to F3
where it X-rays and attacks the D5 Pawn
black is in trouble here white is
clearly better
so this would be one way that black
enters a worse end game some of you are
proposing H6 here which is a totally
natural move to stop Bishop G5 here the
bishop develops to F4 and again white
gets very free and easy play with his
pieces whereas black is struggling with
a weakness on D5 and a general lack of
peace coordination that can really
really cost them a little bit later in
the game let's say black plays Bishop B7
you bring the Rook over to E1 if black
plays a single inaccurate move like
Queen to D7
Bishop takes H6 and already black is
losing because the g-pawn is overloaded
G takes H6 Queen takes F6 and the game
is already over notice that D4 is never
a problem because the bishop on B7 is
unprotected so
H3 I think is a very worthwhile attempt
black of course can equalize with best
play and the best move here for black
according to sort of modern Theory
uh is is the move C6
and after C6 white plays Queen F3
and as far as I know most people here
like to play Bishop 2 D6 just getting
this bishop on a better Square now I
really like the new move Rook to E1 just
getting the bishop onto a better Square
most popular response to this move is
Rook to B8 and now we play B3 and
suddenly we fee and keto the bishop
which is not that common in the fortnite
scotch but I really like the way that
some players have played this B3 and I
would prefer white here I think white
still has an edge here rookie 8 for
example we can take on E8 and if black
plays Queen takes C8 then we can play
Bishop F4 and go for the dark Square so
the development of the dark squared
Bishop in the fortnite scotch is very
flexible sometimes you develop it to G5
sometimes you feel keto it and sometimes
you bring it out to F4 and the reason
you would bring it out to F4 the reason
that the bishop trade actually favors
white here is very positional if black
trades on F4 look at the weakness of the
dark squares on the queen side all of
these squares are under White's control
also The Rook is hanging and what is the
sort of textbook way we've talked about
this before on the speed run that white
can exploit the weakness of the C5
square and by extension the weakness of
the C6 Pawn what is the sort of textbook
move here
thank you
pause this if you're watching on YouTube
and try to figure it out so you want to
exploit the square on C5 what is the
best piece to exploit a weak Square
width well it's the Knight and therefore
Knight to A4 is a pretty classic move
you're aiming for C5 but mainly you're
just immobilizing the C6 Pawn you're not
allowing black to play the move C6 to C5
so let's say the black goes I don't know
Rook to E7 here you can play B4 and
really accentuate your control over that
square notice how you're clamping down
on Black's Pawn Chain by controlling the
C5 square and even if black trades Rooks
here that doesn't actually help Black's
cause because ultimately black is going
to pay the price for these incredibly
weak pawns on the queen side you're
threatening to infiltrate with your
queen and you can play positionally by
establishing a blockade on C5
so this is just a very brief overview of
how quickly things can go wrong for
black even if they make natural looking
moves and we will definitely have an
opportunity probably in a hundred points
or so to delve deeper into the into the
weeds here this is just a an
introductory Exposition but in short if
black plays the main move which is D5
you take you play H3 you deploy your
queen to F3 and then based on the setup
the black chooses you either bring the
bishop out to G5 if black drops the
bishop back to D6 you often want to
trade dark squared Bishops but you also
should keep in mind the fianchetto which
aims both Bishops at Black's King
okay hopefully that made some sense now
let's get to the game continuation uh
which is very common at a club player
level and that's D6 so Bishop G5 is a
very direct move it is not the only move
to challenge black I think the engine
stop move believe it or not is Knight A4
but I wholeheartedly recommend that you
play Bishop G5 because the engine stop
choice is really really crazy here
according to the computer black actually
has to go G5 and this doesn't solve
Black's problems white is still better
here
because after Bishop G3 the pawn on G5
sticks out like a sore thumb and the way
that you exploit a pawn like this is by
pushing F4 and Blasting open the king's
side so let's say the black plays uh a
neutral move let's say the black plays
Rook to B8 here you automatically play
the move F4 and black is already busted
there was one game in the database where
black played Bishop to G4
white calmly blocked the attack with his
Bishop black delivered a check on C5
which is totally useless black is
already losing King H1
Bishop takes E2 Queen takes C2 black
centralized the bishop and white blasted
open the center with E5
and after rookie 8 F takes G5
black played Knight H7 and white played
G6
and after H takes F takes G6 Queen C4
black resigned because he lost the
bishop in the center so that was the
game 2000 versus an unrated from 2000.
so that's a good illustration of how
wrong sinks can go now black can try to
do something about the threat of f4 Rook
E8 uh is one of the main lines here and
if white plays F4 prematurely then
Bishop G4 can actually be a pretty nasty
idea because the E4 Pawn is going to be
a weakness in a lot of these positions
if white plays Queen E1 then there's
like Knight takes E4 Bishop E4 and F5
and things get really really messy here
so there's no reason to rush with F4 in
response to Rook E8 the best move is
just to play rookie one and reinforce
this Pawn black is still in big trouble
and F4 is still a problem Bishop to G4
is the main move now we bring our Queen
up to D2 now you see why you put the
Rook on E1 now Knight takes C4 is no
longer a problem if black plays Knight
to H5 then we can chase the bishop away
with H3
the bishop is forced to drop back let's
say Bishop E6 and we and we play Bishop
to H2 our position is fantastic Black's
Pawn structure is terrible and the key
thing to understand is that you don't
have to rush F4 you can just make
improving moves and enjoy your position
and then play F4 when the moment is
right so long story short G5 does not
solve virtually any of Black's problems
but it's still Black's best move okay so
in this game black missed his
opportunity and played rookie 8 here F4
is automatic because G5 is no longer a
problem and I would go so far as to say
that black is maybe not totally lost
but borderline lost because G5 is never
going to be prop possible this pin is
essentially Eternal the only way the
black eradicates this pin is by moving
the queen out of the way but the moment
he does that we take on F6 we play Queen
H5 and black and resign the H6 bond is
hanging I see a couple of games in the
database King G7 Rook F3 the game is
over Rook is coming to G3 and black is
getting completely steamrolled on the
king side one game in the database
continued Rook h8
and now the best move
is not Rook G3 check because that helps
the king get to a safer spot it's
actually Queen to H4 this is a really
instructive move it's a prophylactic
move because it aims at the F6 pawn and
it stops the king from escaping to f8
and if black tries to reinforce the pawn
then white plays E5
and only if black plays F takes E5 does
white deliver this Chuck and black loses
the queen and gets checkmated because
the connection between the rook and the
queen is intercepted by Black's own King
if black takes with the other Pawn then
obviously we play F take C5 and it
should be very clear to you the black's
position is collapsing at the seams the
bishop is also hanging not that that
matters I mean we're just gonna blast
through on the F5
so after F4 the game is essentially over
our opponent just didn't know what to do
and that's why he played
you know a pretty
neutral move like A5 which just gives us
more time to accumulate the pressure on
the king side which is why we had the
time to play a move like King H1 and I
think this should be the main takeaway
for intermediate players who are
watching this game which is that when
you get a position like this there is a
major temptation to just crash through
with E5 and if you crash through at the
wrong moment you can get burned for it
as we would have if we had gone for this
position here black has the Intermezzo
Queen D4 check hits the bishop hits the
king Bishop has to block black takes on
E5 and black is completely fine right
there's nothing left of our attack so it
the the importance of understanding
whether you're in a hurry and if you're
not in a hurry then making a single move
like this a single move that improves
your position improves the safety of
your king can greatly increase the
probability that your attack succeeds
okay
and again all of this time we're not
afraid of Bishop takes C3 this doesn't
actually do anything for black because
the E4 Pawn is safely defended and it's
safely defended because this Knight is
permanently pinned hopefully that makes
sense
okay any questions thus far
all right
hopefully
my explanations have made sense so after
King H1 okay our opponent played Bishop
C5 we deployed the queen to F3 and
according to the engine yes it was
possible instead to play E5 it was
possible it was possible to do this and
after Rook takes C5 the correct move is
Bishop F6 gf6
and now
all Bishop H7 I didn't see that for some
reason I completely forgot about the
X-ray oh so E5 was in fact winning on
the spot yeah I just didn't pay
attention to this x-ray
so that's another thing to file into
your mental directory especially because
this bishop is very rarely undeveloped
for so long so I think in my mind it
didn't occur to me that the queen could
possibly be undefended oh actually after
rookie five you could already Play
Bishop H7 you don't even need to take on
F6 but it's a good idea to do that so E5
was winning on the spot but we played
Queen F3 doesn't really ruin anything
because black is so helpless King h8
and E5 probably would have been more
tenacious for black to develop to defend
the C6 Pawn if I was playing Blacky I
would play Bishop D7 uh but here
probably we can still play E5 and this
is the square clearance idea here the
best move is to put more pressure on
this Knight with Knight to E4 because
this attacks the bishop this attacks the
Knight and after the bishop drops back
now we take back on E5 and after black
takes on e4 white takes on F7 King h8
Bishop takes E4 and we finish things off
in this position with what move who can
find a very straightforward way to end
the attack
Queen to G6 is simple and Incredibly
powerful this builds battery and notice
the role of the f-file control after
King J Queen H7 is mate because the king
can't escape down the file so I'm a
little bit upset that I didn't
find the immediate E5 but our position
is so overwhelming and black is so
paralyzed that we can basically do
whatever we want
now some of you were worried about
Bishop to G4 Bishop G4 has nothing to
worry about because it loses a piece and
it loses a piece not to this move which
is very tempting for newer players but
this is an equal trade because you take
a piece and then you give up a piece
instead you start by taking Black's
Knight you've taken one piece if black
takes then the bishop loses its Defender
if Bishop takes Queen then Bishop takes
Queen and now both Bishops are hanging
and black loses a piece either black
takes on d8 and we take on F3 or black
moves this bishop and then we move our
Bishop either back or we take the pawn
okay so pretty straightforward stuff but
even if we didn't have that the queen
can always Park itself on G3 and this is
a square that you should generally be
familiar with it's a very nice attacking
Square for the queen in a wide variety
of openings so Bishop to G4 is just not
scary in general now there is an
exception to this even within the scotch
Gambit uh sorry within the fortnite
scotch which is that there is a
well-known trap when black plays into
the main line so here again my
recommendation is H3 but in the main
line
it's very important to avoid after Queen
F3 H6 the move Bishop to H4 this is
famously bad because black plays G5
forces the bishop back and suddenly
Bishop G4 basically traps the queen
because the queen doesn't have this G3
square and if the queen moves to the
side then black Forks the queen in the
night with D4 so amazingly white has a
way to escape like immediate loss with
Bishop C7 but black is worse
so that's just like one caveat when the
bishop is forced onto G3 but in the game
continuation there's no way for black to
force this bishop away because G5 is
never possible
okay so the rest of the game was very
straightforward and the other takeaway
is that you shouldn't tunnel vision the
area of the board where you're attacking
right you should be aware at all times
of the def of the defects of your
opponent's position but on both sides of
the board I was aware that the Rook was
undefended I was aware that the bishop
was undefended I was aware that the
queen was x-raying the C6 Pawn which may
seem insignificant but no tactical
factor is ever insignificant
particularly when your position is this
overwhelming and your opponent's
position is this underdeveloped okay so
just seeing what's going on everywhere
in the board can just allow you to find
a move like Queen takes C6 with relative
ease the rest of the game uh does not uh
Merit any commentary we just took on G7
won the piece and the rest of the game
is very straightforward we just mopped
up all the pawns and delivered checkmate
so a very simple game
slightly you know plain vanilla meat and
potatoes but it was I think a good
introduction to the mainline for night
scotch
again you know I would review some of
the theory after D5 I'm sure that we'll
face it again but D6 is a really bad
move because the bishop G5 and this is
the beauty of this opening you're
basically forcing black to find a long
sequence of accurate theoretical moves
just to get a playable position and even
then I think that White's position is
practically a lot easier to play
that's why the fortnite scotch is my
main recommendation
okay thank you everybody hope you
enjoyed the speedrun game today it's
already 5 a.m oh cram Nick's online we
gotta challenge him
thank you everybody I'll see everybody
later I will try to stream tomorrow but
no guarantees gonna get some sleep see
you guys everybody bye
[Music]